foreign
welcome today we are in the trees last
week we started a conversation about
some things to consider if you're
interested in starting van life we left
off with this very important question
why are you the way that you are this
one is still very much unanswered we're
gonna move past it for now and focus on
overnight parking
before I moved on to the road this is
the thing that freaked me out the most
like leading up to the day my apartment
lease expired I did as much research as
I could to figure out where I should
stay overnight my first night on the
road was spent parking right outside the
apartment building I had just moved out
of I still had the parking permit so I
felt pretty safe and legal staying there
then I started driving 38 minutes each
way toward the mountains every morning
and every night just to camp in the
forest it's funny how back then I
thought that was such a life hack to be
sleeping for free in the forest and now
there's no way I would drive that far
without staying for at least a few days
after about two weeks of that I left for
Utah to properly hit the road and that's
when I began to really see what was out
there in terms of wild camping there was
a lot of trial and error involved and a
lot of mistakes made along the way but
over time I began to develop pretty good
handle on how and where to find safe
parking spots in the past five years
I've developed a pretty solid Archive of
places to stay and what I can can expect
there so finding a place to park at
night has become mostly a non-issue so
what makes a solid overnight camping
spot first check the weather I've
learned the hard way to always check
this first before committing to a
location
you've narrowed down your search to a
region the Baseline criteria is a place
that is safe legal and accessible sounds
simple but it's not always easy not all
roads are created equally and Google
Maps or map app can be a useful resource
in zooming in to see what you're working
with but even that only goes so far and
I've also learned this one the hard way
by almost getting stuck at least on two
separate occasions that I can remember
one time was in waist deep snow when I
was still in my Xterra and another time
I think it was last year in the desert
during a sudden rainstorm I was driving
along and suddenly started sinking like
drastically on a dirt road and I had to
floor it in reverse in the middle of the
night I couldn't see what was behind me
it was very scary to not do not
recommend next I'm looking for a spot
that is level and at least somewhat
quiet
head needs to go in one of those corners
and now
okay head needs to go in that corner and
that's how I work out which way to sleep
every night this is especially relevant
in urban areas where you might be
dealing with garbage trucks or street
sweepers or bus stops it's more
important to have a level spot in the
city because you wouldn't want to pull
out leveling blocks on a residential
street because it's a clear sign that
you're sleeping there as opposed to Wild
camping where you can make hilly terrain
work by just driving up onto blocks next
I check to see if I have cell service or
if you have starlink then check for a
clear connection and then I'm assessing
how far I'll need to drive to refill my
water tanks resupply my food take a
shower and whether or not there is a
post office UPS or FedEx where I can
receive any necessary shipments for work
finally I'm looking for a place with a
beautiful view that is either in or near
natural landscapes or parks where I can
hike and also potentially film and
photograph so let's start with one of
the more expensive but obvious options
campgrounds I could count on two hands
just how many times I paid to sleep in a
campground the first three years I lived
on the road the way I see it if you're
planning to do this long term paying for
campsites on a regular basis isn't
exactly sustainable because those days
can really add up most campgrounds I've
stayed at average about forty dollars a
night and if you multiply that by 30
that's twelve hundred dollars twelve
hundred dollars for a place just to park
like you might as well just get an
apartment at that point unless of course
you're doing it purely for the
experience in which case it does make
sense because you're able to travel and
see beautiful places without paying the
even higher price of a hotel or an
Airbnb but the main reason why I don't
stay in campgrounds very often is
because I find most of them lack the
kind of Stillness and immersion in
nature that I'm actually seeking out
here on the road in my experience I'm
usually tucked in between families with
young kids and pets and or RVs with
generators and big screen TVs and hey
that's cool like camping is for everyone
we're all entitled to Camp with as much
or as little comfort as We crave but I
personally like to hear the sounds of
nature and also like be able to walk
around outside maybe in my swimsuit and
take a shower without feeling like I'm
in a small town center of sorts I don't
always find what I'm looking for but I'm
not really a fan of paying for something
that I don't even want if that makes
sense okay next truck stops and rest
areas Travel America Love truck stops
and Pilot gas stations
I've probably slept in these about five
percent of the time I personally find
them to be really loud with bright
lights and generators that run all
through the night same goes for most
rest stops although I've probably spent
more time staying at these just because
they're so convenient whenever I'm doing
a long-haul drive and I need a place to
tuck in for the night I have found that
Oregon rest stops are my favorite some
of them are really quiet gems where I've
literally been the only vehicle there
and I've sat outside and actually
watched the stars at night which is
really nice but otherwise I generally
prefer a wild camping spot to a rest
area if it's an option the majority of
my nights are spent wild camping on BLM
which is the Bureau of Land Management
State lands and National Forest lands
this is a map of our public lands here
in the United States I often get asked
why I haven't ventured East with the van
and this is honestly the main reason why
the camping out west is so plentiful and
there are way fewer people and more
space with less development as a person
who can appreciate my fellow humans but
doesn't necessarily want to always see
them the West is really just more my
style these are the places where you'll
find the beautiful views and the
sweeping Landscapes the quiet Solitude
of nature there are really and truly so
many gems and places to explore that
once you understand how to scout them
out the options are pretty endless some
downsides to Wild camping might include
limited or no access to amenities like a
shower or the ability to restock
Essentials like food or gas water you
might also feel a little more exposed
from a safety aspect depending on your
comfort level disconnected from society
and you're kind of susceptible to
Wildlife like rodents trying to take up
residence in your vehicle or maybe Bears
roaming through your campsite still it's
my favorite option and if it were no
longer possible to Wild Camp I would
quit band life today like without
question how do I find these places
when I first started out I leaned pretty
heavily on the app I Overlander and
freecampsites.net and as time went on I
began branching out from those locations
to find spots that were less crowded but
in similar landscapes one really great
way to do this is by using the satellite
version of Google Maps or Google Earth
I'm sure you all know this already but
just in case you don't in many locations
you can take that little person icon and
plop it down on the map so that you can
see an eye level view of a spot on the
map and that has helped me really
understand if there are Gates blocking
Force roads or other obstacles that
might not be visible from above it is in
foolproof but it's just an extra tool to
help in scouting a new spot sometimes
once I've arrived to an area I'll pop up
my drone to search for a campsite before
committing to driving down like a really
gnarly Road this is pretty helpful but I
would just remind you to be sure droning
is legal wherever you happen to do it
back to the topic of using apps like I
Overlander or relying on popular blog
posts with geocordinates
I have mixed emotions about these it's
true that they were really helpful to me
as a starting point but there are quite
a few places I can think of that used to
be pristine and relatively unknown five
years ago that are now overrun with
campers littered with trash and in some
cases closed all together or requiring
permits Sedona Road 525 used to be a
camping Haven and is now so overrun that
I hear they've actually closed most of
it off to Camping
um maybe some of you can confirm that
Alabama Hills is another example and one
of my favorite places on Whidbey Island
it was shut down this past summer after
locals just got tired of trash being
left around and honestly I don't blame
them like imagine growing up in a place
where you were able to enjoy nature with
little to no people around and all of a
sudden the places just trampled and kind
of destroyed and always occupied by
strangers many of you ask if I could
provide a resource with pinpoints of my
favorite places to stay or you might
message privately and ask for specific
locations and in summer situations I do
share
and I know there are a lot of travel
influencers and bloggers out there who
do provide resources like that but I
personally feel conflicted on this issue
I see both sides as someone who grew up
in a city surrounded by farmland and
devoid of mountains oceans and forests
I believe everyone should have access to
these beautiful places
at the same time I can't deny that
social media and over sharings had a lot
of negative impacts on these places and
I hesitate to contribute any more than I
already have and like I realize this is
an oversimplification of the issue and
it's many many sides but I personally
believe that in most cases discovering a
location for yourself and knowing what
to look for is an important part of the
process putting in the work and research
builds confidence and the skills
necessary to persist in this kind of
Lifestyle it's like that old saying give
a man a fish and he eats for a day but
teach him men to fish and he'll eat for
a lifetime equally if not more important
is the need to protect these places by
treating them with respect by picking up
trash and just leaving a place better
than you found it we have to each
individually want to care for these
places and at least for now for me I
think that choosing to not share them
publicly is one way to do that I've also
chosen not to share for safety reasons
the archive I've built of my favorite
campsites are places I return to again
and again and many of them are seasonal
and if you also follow me on Instagram
and do just a tiny amount of research it
wouldn't be that hard to narrow down
where I might be spending my nights and
that just isn't a risk that I want to
expose myself to on the topic of safety
even if a place checks all the boxes if
something feels off trust your gut and
move on to the next place I've done this
myself a handful of times and though I
can't tell you exactly why I decided to
leave I know that it was always the
right choice I actually put together a
video about this a while back which I
would suggest you check out after this
one because safety plays a big role in
finding quality overnight campsites and
rather than repeat myself too much here
I'll just say that anything is possible
anywhere at any time and having
awareness and being prepared are your
two greatest defenses against finding
yourself in a compromising situation
that said living like this is not nearly
as scary as it might seem from the
outside on the whole I tend to feel much
safer in Wild camping spots than I do in
cities and the two scariest incidents
I've personally had on the road were
both on the outskirts of large cities
the first one happened during the first
few months I hit the road I was parked
on some desert land in Southern
California kind of on the outskirts of
LA and sometime around 3 A.M I just
randomly woke up and looked out the
windshield and there were these
headlights in the distance coming just
straight toward me
and there hadn't been anyone around me
when I fell asleep so it seemed like
rather odd and then I realized the
lights were picking up speed like
quickly coming straight in my direction
so I left into the driver's seat and
literally just skirt out of there in the
middle of the night and I have no idea
if they had any intention of approaching
me it could have been totally harmless I
just didn't stick around to find out the
second time I was parked along the ocean
in the forest and I had all of my window
covers up so I couldn't see anything but
for some odd reason I woke up at 2 am
and removed the window cover of my side
window just above where I was sleeping
like this and there were headlights
pointed straight at me
I was pretty disoriented at first but
then I realized that a large truck had
me T-boned in a huge parking lot and
like no one else was there like it was
an empty parking lot and they had me
T-boned
and as I was staring at it just like
blinking it suddenly backed up and just
peeled out of the parking lot I'm
guessing they saw my face in the window
or something like that
I have also stayed in places where no
one physically came around to bother me
but there were clear indications that
campers and non-locals were just not
wanted
[Applause]
what even is that
holy this is so gross
why do people do this
I have been parked in this spot for four
hours it's quiet only one truck drove by
and kind of slowed down when they drove
by but otherwise there's been no one up
here since it's getting
darker
I'm just realizing that once it's pitch
dark here
I'm not so sure I'm gonna feel super
safe I'd probably be absolutely fine but
I was reading reviews on I Overlander of
a place pretty close to here they said
that at 1am
um three different trucks were driving
by with their brights on and making loud
noises and they felt super sketched out
and unsafe so
I just don't want to risk it because
there's literally no one else up here as
far as I can tell one person actually
said they pulled up to the site and they
got
um
locals gonna kill Vibes so I've just
decided to keep driving it's 40 minutes
to the coast and I still don't know
where I'm gonna spend the night they
have a city ordinance against parking
there at night so I might have to get a
campground or the hotels are only like
60 dollars so I've made the executive
decision
to not risk staying here goodbye
campsite
now stealth camping versus wild camping
I've already mentioned that I lean
really heavily in the direction of wild
camping but I also do stealth Camp from
time to time usually when I'm stuck in a
city waiting on a package to arrive or I
have an appointment of some kind or I'm
meeting up with friends otherwise I
personally like to stay as far away from
the cities as possible there are quite a
lot of fan lifers who spend the majority
of their time in cities and they do make
it work so it's definitely possible if
that's what you're aiming to do when I
say stealthy I don't mean camping
illegally I'm referring to finding safe
places to park in cities and counties
where it's legal to sleep in your car
the laws are really varied when it comes
to this so it's always best to do your
own research in San Luis Obispo for
example the finest something like 300 if
you're caught sleeping in your vehicle
and in Sedona if I remember correctly I
saw a sign that said the fine was five
thousand dollars which is just like some
of the places I've personally stayed
Walmart of course but to be honest
probably only like 20 to 30 times total
over over the past five years always
when I'm in transit
um Cracker Barrel like five times and I
have stayed on residential streets in
some states and cities there are
ordinances against sleeping overnight in
your vehicle so sleeping at a Walmart or
Cracker Barrel isn't always an option
also I have to say that things seem to
be shifting when it comes to Walmart and
their willingness to let us stay there
overnight I don't know tell me what you
guys have experienced in the comments
but the last one that I stayed at it was
a little over a year ago and the parking
lot had these loud speakers that blared
rock music all night long I low-key got
the impression that they didn't want me
there also when I look on the I
Overlander app I tend to come across
more and more locations that read this
place marked as closed including some
Walmarts and Cracker Barrels honestly it
makes sense that this would happen
especially after so many people hit the
road in 2020 and many of these places
just saw like a drastic uptick in
overnight camping but it is discouraging
to think that rather than this being
like a positive thing in the sense that
we're all being respectful and actually
supporting the places we stay by loading
up on groceries or whatever there are
enough of us out there that are allowed
messy disrespectful or whatever else you
might imagine would Inspire business
owners to shut us out it's a bummer and
it sucks and I hate it let's talk about
what it means to not be an apple when
you are self-camping number one don't
overstay your welcome AKA don't stay in
a spot too often or hang around the
night before or morning after I try to
find a handful of potential options and
then switch it up every couple of nights
by rotating between each spot typically
my city-based evenings involve parking
at a public park until closing time
where I'll make my bed brush my teeth
and just do my whole evening routine
before driving over to my sleeping spot
that way I can tuck in right when I
arrive and then leave first thing in the
morning if you're really doing it right
people living nearby won't even know you
were ever there hence the term stealth
another tip is to use some form of
privacy curtains or window covers I use
magnetic covers from fan-made gear they
have reflectix materials sewn into them
so they insulate the windows from both
the Heat and the cold and they easily
fold up for storage during the day I
also have this privacy blackout curtain
that I secure with a magnet and all
these things combined completely block
out my van at night so that nothing is
visible from the outside even if I turn
one of the lights on I have seen vans
that use foil looking covers or actual
curtains and while this is effective at
blocking out the light it might tip
someone off that you're sleeping in your
vehicle for the same reason I always
make sure that my front cab is clear of
clutter or anything that shots hey I
live in my car not only to deter theft
but also just to blend in with other
vehicles on the street I would suggest
being mindful about running your fan and
or heater all night that isn't always
possible but it can tip someone off that
you're inside crack the window so that
you can avoid the buildup of
condensation that's dead giveaway one
more weird tip that may or may not be
useful but I use I still have my
overnight parking permit from my last
apartment there's no date on it so
sometimes I'll throw that up in my
rearview mirror along with my national
parks pass if I think there's a chance
of getting a knock I don't know if that
makes any real difference probably not
but if I saw a parking pass on someone's
Dash I would be more likely to assume
that that person does have a home and
they're probably just visiting a friend
in street parking for the night when
parking in a residential area I'm
usually scrolling around Google Maps
looking for a large Park of some kind
and whether or not there's parking
anywhere along the park boundaries so
that I'm not parking directly in front
of someone's house another option is to
look for Corner spaces where there's a
lot of visible green Greenery like trees
or shrubs or also a sparsely populated
industrial area just some place where
I'm not inconveniencing anyone I'm out
of the way and I can more or less be
invisible tuck in Tuck out when I was
living in my SUV my biggest personal
issue with stealth camping was the fact
that I couldn't use the bathroom in the
middle of the night because my rig
didn't have any kind of toilet since
getting a van that's no longer an issue
but to all my ladies out there who are
considering moving into a smaller
vehicle and stealth camping this is
something to keep in mind this is one
area where all you guys out there have a
major built-in Advantage just keep a
water bottle on hand and make sure you
label it clearly a couple other options
I want to mention renting land or
someone's driveway I haven't done this
but I could see it being a solid option
for anyone who has an in-person job in a
certain location or even if you just
want a little built-in stability
airbnb's hotels houses staying at a
friend's house this probably accounts
for 30 percent of my time on the road
though this is heavily skewed by the
past two years and also 2020. my first
two years on the road I had very few
breaks from sleeping in my vehicle
but if you're anything like me you may
find that with time having balance
between time on the road and downtime is
really key to sustaining this lifestyle
and your sanity long term a lot of you
have asked what house sitting platform I
use I use trusted house sitters and know
this is not sponsored by them but I am a
huge fan
[Music]
so is it difficult to find overnight
camping
yes and no I think as with most things
it takes some time and practice to
really figure out what works for you I
will say this is something that has
gotten easier with time it took me a
couple weeks to really start feeling
confident in my ability to find safe and
comfortable places to sleep also it was
far easier to park overnight in my SUV
than it is in the van because the SUV
had more of the stealth factor and it
was also 4x4 so I could just go to more
remote camping spots that my van could
potentially reach but I don't always
want to risk it these days I generally
don't even start thinking about where I
want to spend the night until like 7 or
8 PM because it just becomes second
nature to figure that out on the Fly
there's always the possibility a cop
might knock on your door in the middle
of the night this has happened to me
twice but not the way you might expect
not the way I expected one time uh I was
sleeping overnight at a mountain pass
because I was gonna hike the next
morning all of a sudden I hear this
knock on the door open it up there's two
police officers standing there and
they're like ma'am
are you okay
and I said yeah why and they said well
we got received a phone call from
someone saying there was screaming here
in the area and you're the only vehicle
here and I was like oh
interesting well it wasn't me
and he like peeks his head in and sees
my my ex he backs up again and mouths to
me it's like silently are you okay I was
like aha yeah I'm fine he was like okay
but that freaked me out someone screamed
up here there's no other vehicles
something's going on in the woods let's
get out of here the other time was in
the middle of the day a cop came up and
wrapped on my door here
and I opened it up and he was like
hey do you sleep in here and I was like
oh I didn't know what to say and so I
was just like yeah and he goes that's so
cool my girlfriend really wants to buy
one of these and I've not actually seen
the interior of one not what I expected
but honestly I haven't had any issues
with that
back on wood but I am very mindful about
where I sleep and I really don't take
that many risks there is one other time
though that I did get a ticket I slept
on the 101 in Big Sur the one-on-one
Highway and the cop didn't even knock he
just left a ticket and walked away so
but that's really the only time that
I've really encountered an issue with
overnight parking I will leave you with
this final note
it's really important that we are
respectful of the places we pass through
and park for the night let me give you
an example one time I was staying in an
Airbnb in Portland and a minivan pulled
up right outside the house they opened
up all the doors started unloading their
belongings from the van organizing and
just cleaning everything to include
dumping Two Pea bottles onto the road
all directly within the view of the
living room window where we were sitting
and look sometimes you will find
yourself in awkward moments out on the
road I know that I have but whatever you
do
don't be that person that dumps a pee
bottle in front of someone's house
okay like just don't do it that was way
longer than I expected it to be
um I really hope that you guys found
some value in this let me know in the
comments below as well as any other tips
you want to add that maybe you found
helpful when it comes to overnight
parking and yeah the ends I love you
guys I'll see you soon